WHOO!
Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL"--
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
BE IN JAMAICA!
Women: (screaming)
Tyra: THE 14 FINALISTS
FLEW TO JAMAICA FOR
THEIR VERY FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
CASSIE, A STUDENT AND EXOTIC
DANCER FROM OKLAHOMA,
STRUGGLED WITH POSING.
Man: GREAT.
Tyra: AMANDA, A MOTHER WITH A
DEGENERATIVE EYE DISEASE,
SHOWED PROMISE.
Man: KAMA SUTRA.
Tyra: AND JULIE HIT A HOME RUN
HER FIRST TIME AT BAT.
Jay: LOSE THE QUESTION
MARK IN THE FACE.
Tyra: WHEN MAGDALENA FAILED TO
CONNECT WITH THE CAMERA...
Magdalena: BYE, GUYS.
Tyra: SHE BECAME THE FIRST
MODEL TO BE SENT HOME.
Women: (screaming)
Tyra: BACK IN NEW YORK, THE
GIRLS MOVED
INTO THEIR NEW CRIB.
THEN IT WAS TIME TO MEET THE
JUDGING PANEL.
Janice: THE HAND COMING THROUGH
YOUR LEGS LOOKS
LIKE SOMETHING
THAT IS ON A MAN.
Nigel: INTERESTING EYES,
BUT THEY'RE SORT
OF POSSESSED.
Tyra: IN THE END, LEAH'S
AWKWARDNESS IN HER PHOTOS
COST HER THE COMPETITION.
12 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Cassie: MY STOMACH HURTS
'CAUSE I NEED SOME FOOD.
I'M SO HUNGRY.
I THOUGHT
I WAS GONNA PASS OUT.
I'M VERY OBSESSED
WITH MY WEIGHT,
AND I'M
OBSESSED ABOUT WHAT I EAT.
Cassie: I'M DETERMINED
TO BE A MODEL,
AND IF I HAVE
TO BE SKINNY
TO BE A MODEL, I WILL BE.
Amanda: ♪ ITSY-BITSY SPIDER ♪
♪ CRAWLED UP THE WATER SPOUT ♪
♪ DOWN CAME-- ♪♪
Baby: (screams)
Amanda: UH-HUH,
HI, BABY.
I MISS YOU, ELI.
ELIJAH IS MY LIGHT,
MY JA-WOLF.
Eli: (crying)
Amanda: MAMA LOVES ELI.
HE IS THE MOST MAGICAL
CHILD I HAVE EVER SEEN
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
HE WAS CONCEIVED
TO THE HOUR
ON SEPTEMBER 11th.
OOH, THANK YOU.
Yaya: NOW THIS IS THE MOMMY OF
THE HOUSE.
Amanda: I'M THIS, LIKE,
WONDERFUL, LOVING, HIPPIE MOM
THAT WANTS EVERYBODY
TO LOVE EACH OTHER.
WHENEVER ANYBODY NEEDS
SOMETHING,
ASK ME AND
I'LL GET IT.
Cassie: I'M FULL NOW.
OHH.
♪♪♪
Eva: TYRA MAIL.
Ann: "LONG, SHORT, DARK, LIGHT,
IT DOESN'T MATTER, WE'LL
MAKE IT RIGHT.
Women: (screaming)
Ann: "BE READY AT 9:45 A.M."
Eva: SO THERE WAS TYRA
MAIL, AND CLEARLY,
WE WERE GONNA
HAVE A MAKEOVER.
♪♪♪
Jay: GOOD MORNING.
All: GOOD MORNING,
JAY.
Jay: WE'RE HERE AT
THE PETER COPPOLA SALON.
YOU'RE HERE TO GET A MAKEUP
LESSON FROM ME,
AND I'M GONNA
TEACH YOU GUYS
HOW TO GET A CLEAN,
FRESH, NATURAL
LOOK USING
COVER
GIRL COSMETICS TODAY.
SO IF WE'RE HERE
IN A HAIR SALON,
IT ONLY MAKES SENSE THAT
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
GET HAIR MAKEOVERS
AS WELL.
AND WITH ME, I'VE
GOT ANTHONY POLERMO,
AND THIS IS LEONARD ZAGOMI.
Kelle: I'M FREAKING OUT,
LIKE, OH, MY, GOD,
WHAT ARE THEY GONNA DO?
Tyra: HELLO.
OH, HEY, GIRLS.
YOU GUYS LOOK LIKE
THE PRETTY GIRLS
WALKIN' DOWN THE STREET,
LIKE, "I THINK SHE CAN MODEL,
BUT HMM..."
SO I'M GONNA START
WITH YOU, KELLE.
SO YOU'RE GONNA GET LONG, WAVY,
BIG HAIR EXTENSIONS.
Tyra: JULIE,
WE DECIDED TO CUT 6 TO 8 INCHES
OFF OF YOUR HAIR, AND
GIVE YOU
A LITTLE BIT OF MOVEMENT.
YAYA, I LOVE THE FACT THAT YOU
KEEP YOUR HAIR NATURAL.
IT SHOWS THE PRIDE THAT YOU
HAVE AS A BLACK WOMAN,
BUT I AM GONNA TAKE
YOUR BRAIDS OUT
TO MAKE YOU MORE VERSATILE.
YAYA, WHAT IS YOUR BIGGEST
INSECURITY?
Yaya: MY SKIN.
Tyra: I FOUND ONE OF THE BEST
DERMATOLOGISTS IN NEW YORK CITY.
All: WHOO-HOO! YEAH.
Tyra: AND YOU'RE GONNA
BE SEEING HER TODAY.
ANN, WE DECIDED TO
MAKE YOU BLONDE.
NICOLE, I SEE YOU IN
"I LOVE LUCY" RED.
Woman: OOH...
Tyra: TOCCARA, WHAT WE
WANNA DO IS
ADD A LITTLE
BIT OF LENGTH
AND A HELL OF
A LOT OF THICKNESS.
KRISTI, WE'RE GONNA
MAKE YOU MORE EDGY,
SO WE'RE GONNA GIVE
YOU A LONG BANG
THAT'S GONNA BE VERY CHIC.
JENNIPHER, LET'S SEE THESE
LOCKS.
SO YOU HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH US
CHOPPING ALL OF IT
OFF TO RIGHT HERE.
Jennipher: (whimpers)
Tyra: AND YOU'RE GOING
VERY, VERY BLONDE,
BUT WE ARE GONNA DONATE YOUR
HAIR TO LOCKS OF LOVE.
(applause)
Tyra: CASSIE, YOU ARE GETTING
HAIR WEAVED FOR THICKENING.
AMANDA, WE WANNA MATCH
THOSE ICY BLUE EYES
WITH SOME
ICY BLONDE HAIR.
Amanda: AAH! WORK IT.
Tyra: EVA, I LOVE
THE FACT THAT
YOUR HAIR IS SHORT.
I THINK WE NEED
TO KIND OF
SHAPE IT AND TAKE IT
A LITTLE BIT SHORTER.
NORELLE, YOU ARE GOING TO GET
YOUR HAIR CHOPPED OFF,
AND WE HAVE FOUND ONE OF THE
TOP ORTHODONTISTS,
AND THOSE ARE
COMING OFF TODAY.
Norelle: OH, MY GOD!
(cheers and applause)
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, ARE
YOU GUYS READY?
All: YES!
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
LET'S GO!
♪♪♪
Man: READY?
Cassie: YEAH,
LET'S DO IT.
Nicole: IN REACTION
TO THEIR MAKEOVERS,
SOME ARE SUPER EXCITED.
Norelle: I'M SO EXCITED,
'CAUSE, LIKE, I'VE NEVER
SEEN MYSELF WITHOUT BRACES.
Kelle: I'M SO EXCITED.
Nicole: SOME ARE NOT
SO HAPPY.
Woman: YOU'LL BE FINE.
Eva: IT'S GONNA BE
LITTLE AND BLONDE,
LIKE A LITTLE
WHITE BOY.
I DON'T WANNA LOOK
LIKE A LITTLE BOY.
I'M JUST NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO CHANGE IT.
I JUST DON'T WANNA
LOOK UGLY, YOU KNOW?
Tyra: WHY ARE YOU CRYIN'?
Eva: I WAS, LIKE--
I DON'T KNOW.
I ALWAYS FEAR
IT, LIKE, TOO SHORT.
I JUST CUT MY HAIR.
IT USED TO BE,
LIKE, REALLY LONG
AND THIS IS, LIKE,
REALLY STILL
GROWING ON ME,
YOU KNOW?
Tyra: THIS IS
THE BIG TIME,
AND THE BIG
TIME IS ABOUT,
LIKE, MAKING REALLY
BIG CHANGES.
Amanda: SOME OF THE
GIRLS WERE KIND OF UPSET.
I TRIED TO BE VERY
KIND AND GIVING,
BUT THAT'S JUST
PART OF ME.
I'M A MAMA. I'M
TRYING TO HELP.
Yaya: ARE YOU GONNA BE SAD?
Amanda: NO, SHE'LL BE FINE.
SHE'LL BE BEAUTIFUL.
Jennipher: DON'T DO THAT.
YOU KNOW, IT'S KIND OF
LIKE A SECURITY BLANKET
KNOWING MY
HAIR'S ALWAYS THERE
TO GET ME RECOGNIZED
OR GET ME SOMEWHERE.
Leonard: YOU READY?
I'M GONNA CUT IT ALL OFF
IN ONE SWIPE.
READY?
Jennipher: (sobbing)
IT FEELS A LOT LIGHTER.
Leonard: YOU
LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
Toccara: I CAN'T WAIT
TO SEE SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE.
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE
GONNA BE LIKE...
Kelle: AMANDA, WITH
HER EYES.
Toccara: OH, WITH THE BLUE EYES
WITH THE
BLONDE.
Kelle: LIKE DOWN TO HERE...
Toccara: I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S GONNA SOUND A LITTLE--
THAT SOUNDS LITTLE SCARY.
Amanda: OH, MY GOSH.
I AM SO EXCITED FOR
THIS NEW LOOK.
I THINK IT'S
GONNA LOOK HOT,
JUST REALLY, REALLY HOT.
MY EYES ARE
JUST GONNA SHINE.
Nicole: THE COLOR'S REALLY
GONNA MAKE ME GO POW.
Tyra: IT'S LINDA
EVANGELISTA.
Nicole: MY MAKEOVER MAKES
ME EDGIER, MORE MODEL.
♪♪♪
Kristi: JAY TAUGHT US ALL
HOW TO GET A CLEAN, FRESH,
NATURAL LOOK WITH
COVER GIRL MAKEUP.
Jay: IT'S JUST A LIGHT
SHIMMER JUST TO BRING
A LITTLE GLOW TO
THE SKIN.
TAKE JUST THE BRONZER. JUST PUT
A LITTLE ON YOUR LID,
JUST RIGHT HERE.
Kristi: I FEEL TOTALLY LIKE A
DIFFERENT PERSON.
Jay: YOU DO?
Kristi: I FEEL LIKE I'VE NEVER
LOOKED LIKE THIS BEFORE
IN MY LIFE.
Toccara: I LOVE IT.
IT'S ACTUALLY--YEAH.
Tyra: IT DOESN'T LOOK
LIKE A WEAVE, RIGHT?
Woman: NO, IT ATTACHES REALLY,
REALLY GOOD.
Tyra: YEAH.
Toccara: YOU CAN SHAVE
MY HEAD OFF BALD,
AND I'LL STILL WALK AROUND HERE
LIKE I'M A GODDESS.
Cassie: I REALLY WANTED A
COMPLETELY NEW LOOK,
BUT I'M HAPPY WITH WHAT I HAVE.
I HAVE TWO TRACKS OF
FAKE HAIR,
AND SO IT'S VERY HEAVY
NOW AND VERY FULL.
Norelle: I'M SUPER EXCITED
ABOUT MY BRACES.
MY HAIR--I'M
SUPER SCARED.
(gasps)
I'M HAVING TO PUT, LIKE, ALL MY
TRUST AND ALL MY FAITH
INTO YOU, AND I DON'T EVEN KNOW
YOU.
(blows raspberry)
Ann: I'M REALLY EXCITED.
I'VE NEVER BEEN
BLONDE BEFORE.
I'M INTERESTED TO SEE
HOW IT'LL LOOK.
I'M VERY OPEN-MINDED
ABOUT IT.
I HATE SHORT HAIR
ON ME.
Anthony: BUT IT'S
NOT SHORT.
Ann: JUST ON ME,
PERSONALLY,
LIKE, I NEED TO GET USED TO IT.
Cassie: I NEVER THOUGHT
I WOULD SEE PEOPLE CRY
OVER HAIR.
I SAW NORELLE CRYING.
I SAW JENNIPHER
CRYING.
I SAW YAYA CRYING,
YOU KNOW?
AND IT'S JUST HAIR.
Eva: I'M NOT REALLY
LOVING IT RIGHT NOW,
BUT, HEY, I'VE
GOTTA DO IT.
Jay: LIKE, YOU'VE GOT A LITTLE
BIT OF HAIR ALONG HERE,
SO WE WANNA LOSE THAT.
Eva: I'M OKAY NOW.
I LOVE THE WAY IT CAME OUT.
I LOVE THE RESULTS
OF THE COLOR.
Ann: JULIE, I THINK,
IS BEAUTIFUL,
BUT I THINK SHE ALSO ONLY HAS
ONE LOOK BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
CHANGE HER HAIR.
Julie: IN SOME
WAY, I GUESS
I SHOULD SEE IT
AS A COMPLIMENT,
LIKE THEY DON'T HAVE
TO DO ANYTHING WITH ME.
Tyra: DO YOU UNDERSTAND
THE MOVEMENT NOW?
AND NOW WHEN YOU'RE
MODELING YOU CAN...
AND NOT JUST BE LIKE, UGH.
Julie: YEAH.
LIKE, I DON'T FEEL LIKE
A DIFFERENT PERSON.
I FEEL LIKE THIS IS ME
AND THIS IS HOW
I SHOULD
BE LOOKING.
Anthony: YAYA,
YOU HAVE ANOTHER APPOINTMENT.
WHEN YOU COME BACK, WE'RE
GONNA FINISH YOU UP.
Woman: LOOK HOW MANY OF
THE WOUNDS ARE BLACKHEADS.
I'M JUST GONNA OPEN
UP THE ONES THAT ARE.
VERY EASY TO
COME OUT, OKAY?
Yaya: I HAD THE BEST OPPORTUNITY
TO GO AND SEE
A DERMATOLOGIST, YOU KNOW, A
REAL DERMATOLOGIST
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
Dr. Jaliman: WE'RE GONNA GIVE
YOU A PRODUCT TO USE,
AND USE IT EVERY OTHER NIGHT,
AND PROBABLY USE MORE
ON YOUR FOREHEAD.
Yaya: JAY TOLD ME ABOUT THE
TRICKS OF MAKING YOUR MAKEUP
LOOK NATURAL AND COVER IT
UP AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
Jay: GO WITH, LIKE,
THE AQUASMOOTH,
WHICH THIS PRODUCT IS LIKE
A HEAVIER, SLICK HOME BASE.
SO THIS WILL GIVE YOU
MORE COVERAGE.
IT DOES COVER EASILY.
Jay: MM-HMM.
Yaya: I JUST
TRANSFORMED.
SO THAT WAS A BOOST OF
CONFIDENCE FOR ME.
♪♪♪
Dr. Zarabi: HOW LONG HAVE YOU
BEEN WEARING THE BRACES FOR?
Norelle: MM, ALMOST TWO YEARS.
Dr. Zarabi: REALLY?
SO YOU'RE ITCHING TO
HAVE THESE OFF.
Norelle: MM-HMM.
I'M THE ONLY ONE
WITH BRACES.
I'M THE ONLY ONE WITH THE
BLING-BLING ON MY GRILL,
OKAY?
Dr. Zarabi: THIS
IS READY FOR SURE.
IN ORDER TO KEEP
THIS BEAUTIFUL RESULT,
WE HAVE TO
WEAR A RETAINER
FOR SIX MONTHS TO A
YEAR OR SO,
ALL RIGHT?
Norelle: THANK YOU. HA!
I FEEL BETTER NOW
ABOUT THE COMPETITION,
ABOUT, LIKE,
HOW I LOOK.
All: (screaming)
Tyra: WOW, LOOK
HOW PRETTY!
Norelle: DON'T I LOOK
SO MUCH BETTER?
Jay: WE'RE GONNA USE THE
TRUBLEND, WHICH IS
GONNA EVEN OUT YOUR SKIN.
JUST START BY BLENDING
UNDERNEATH THE EYES OUT.
Norelle: BLEND FROM THE
EYE OUT.
Jay: DO YOU LIKE IT?
Norelle: MM-HMM.
IT LOOKS GOOD.
THIS IS, LIKE, SO MUCH MORE
EDGIER AND SEXY.
IT'S, LIKE, VERY VERSATILE.
Jennipher: I USED TO LOOK IN THE
MIRROR AND SEE
LONG, GORGEOUS LOCKS--
DARK, OF COURSE,
BUT I'M NOT TOO
HIP ON BLONDE,
AND NOW I'M GONNA BE
A BLONDE.
Kelle: I FEEL VERY GOOD TO KNOW
THAT I'M GETTING GET
MY LITTLE CURLY WEAVE.
I THINK I
COULD DEFINITELY WORK THIS.
THE MORE COMFORTABLE
I GET HERE,
AND LIKE I START TO KIND
OF LET MY HAIR DOWN,
THE MORE COMFORTABLE
I WILL BE
AS A MODEL.
Amanda: I THINK THAT MY
TRANSFORMATION OUTWARDLY
REALLY DID START A
TRANSFORMATION ON THE INSIDE.
Kristi: LOOK HOW
DIFFERENT THAT IS.
Yaya: AMANDA STOOD IN FRONT OF
US, AND SHE DOESN'T
CHANGE HER EXPRESSION.
I WAS LIKE, "OKAY!
TRANSFORMATION INSIDE AND OUT.
SHE'S A DIVA NOW."
Amanda: AS SOON AS I SAW
MYSELF IN THE MIRROR,
I JUST FELT SEXIER
AND MORE POWERFUL.
HMM. MMM.
THE GIRLS ARE STARTING TO FEEL
INTIMIDATED BY ME,
AND THAT'S REALLY MAKING ME FEEL
GOOD AS HELL.
Jay: ANTHONY AND LEONARD
DID AN AMAZING JOB.
I HOPE YOU GUYS LEARNED
A LOT.
ARE YOU HUNGRY?
YOU READY TO GO EAT?
Woman: HAPPY DINNER.
Amanda: OKAY, SO WE'RE BOTH
GETTING THE PENNE VODKA,
THE SOUP OF THE DAY.
Julie: CASSIE IS SUCH
A DIET COKE FREAK.
Eva: THANK YOU, SIR.
ARE YOU NOT EATING ANYTHING,
CASSIE?
ARE YOU NOT
EATING ANYTHING?
Cassie: I'M STARVING
MYSELF NOW.
I'M PLAYING WITH
YOU, EVA.
GET THE FACE OFF.
Amanda: CASSIE JUST
WOULDN'T
EAT VERY MUCH AT DINNER.
Amanda: I JUST STARTED WATCHING
WHAT SHE WAS EATING,
AND IT
WASN'T VERY MUCH.
Cassie: IF I DIDN'T WANNA BE A
MODEL, I WOULD EAT
WHATEVER I WANTED TO AND NOT
WORRY ABOUT IT.
WHENEVER YOU
GET TIME,
I'D LIKE ANOTHER
DIET COKE.
Yaya: PEOPLE STARTED TO OPEN
THEIR EYES,
LIKE, "OH, YEAH,
SHE DOES KINDA NOT EAT."
ALL THESE
LITTLE THINGS,
I THINK, HAVE BEEN BUILDING UP
QUESTION MARKS
IN PEOPLE'S MINDS.
Amanda: FOOD AND TYRA MAIL!
"WASH UP, EAT UP, NO MAKEUP,
HURRY UP AND, OH, PACK UP.
MODELS NEVER KNOW WHEN THEY HAVE
TO TURN THE HEAT UP ."
Ann: YEAH, BABY!
Jennipher: WE GET
IN THE CAR AND WE HEAD DOWN
TO AN INDIAN
RESTAURANT.
Jay: HELLO.
Women: HELLO.
Jay: YESTERDAY I TAUGHT YOU GUYS
HOW TO CREATE
A NATURAL LOOK USING
COVER GIRL MAKEUP.
TODAY I'M GONNA TEST YOU ON WHAT
I TAUGHT YOU YESTERDAY.
SO TO HELP ME JUDGE THIS
CHALLENGE,
COVER GIRL
KIARA KABUKURO.
Kiara: THANK YOU.
Woman: ALL RIGHT! WHOO!
Kiara: FOR ME, BECOMING
A COVER GIRL
HAS BEEN A HIGHLIGHT
IN A VERY BLESSED CAREER
THAT I HAVE HAD.
IT WASN'T TILL I BECAME A COVER
GIRL THAT EVERYBODY
STARTED NOTICING ME.
PEOPLE WOULD
START SAYING,
"EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVER GIRL,"
AND I'M LIKE, AAH!
Julie: I WAS REALLY HAPPY TO SEE
HER, TO SEE THAT
THERE'S DIFFERENT ETHNICITIES
IN THE INDUSTRY.
Julie: AS A WOMAN OF ETHNICITY,
DO YOU, LIKE,
FEEL LIKE YOU
HAVE REALLY
A LOT OF COMPETITION
IN THE MODELING FIELD?
Kiara: I THINK IT'S JUST
COMPETITIVE IN GENERAL.
THESE DAYS, IT'S REALLY
NOT EVEN ABOUT RACE.
IT COULD BE A BLACK GIRL
AGAINST A BLONDE GIRL
FOR A CONTRACT.
Julie: I THINK AMERICA NEEDS A
LITTLE TASTE OF INDIAN MODEL,
SO WHY NOT REPRESENT WITH ME?
Jay: THE PRIZE FOR
TODAY'S CHALLENGE IS
ONE OF YOU WILL BE GOING WITH
KIARA AND MYSELF
TO A VERY FABULOUS INDUSTRY
PARTY WHERE YOU'RE
GONNA MEET ALL THESE INFLUENTIAL
AND BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE.
WE'LL ALL BE GETTING
INTO A LIMOUSINE
WHERE YOU WILL BE DOING
YOUR HAIR, MAKEUP
AND GETTING DRESSED IN
TEN MINUTES ON THE WAY
TO THE PARTY,
AND THIS IS
A REALISTIC SITUATION.
KIARA, I'M SURE YOU'VE GONE FROM
A PARTY...
Kiara: I HAVE DONE THIS. ALL I
HAVE TO SAY--GOOD LUCK.
ALL THE MAKEUP IS OUT THERE.
EVERYTHING WE WORKED
WITH IS OUT THERE.
SO THREE...
TWO...
ONE.
GO.
Amanda: SOMEBODY TAKES
THIS FLYING LEAP ACROSS
EVERYBODY DOWN THE LIMO.
Jennipher: I MEAN,
I'M JUST GRABBING STUFF,
PUTTING IT ON MY LAP.
OKAY.
Kristi: OH, BABY, THIS IS A
PARTY.
(laughter and squeals)
Eva: WHERE IS THE CONCEALER?
Ann: DO YOU HAVE SOME?
Eva: WHAT IS CONCEALER?
Jennipher: WE WERE ELBOWING
EACH OTHER,
AND WE'RE TRYING TO, LIKE,
GET IT ON REAL FAST,
AND IT LOOKED LIKE A BUNCH OF
MANIACS.
LIKE, IT'S SOMETHING YOU'LL
NEVER FORGET.
Eva: SOMEONE'S GONNA GO
TO THE PARTY FUNKY.
Jay: TWO MINUTES LEFT.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES,
AND WE'RE PULLING UP
TO A PARTY.
LOOKIN' CUTE!
I KNOW I LOOK CUTE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU GUYS
RIGHT NOW.
Yaya: THIS IS A REAL CHALLENGE,
BECAUSE I NEED TO MAKE MY
SKIN WORK FOR ME.
Toccara: WHO GOT A BLOUSE?
OH, MY GOD!
Eva: IT WAS A MESS.
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
WHOA!
IT'S SO HOT
IN HERE!
Norelle: AND MY EYE SHADOW
WITH MY FINGER
'CAUSE I DON'T
HAVE BRUSHES.
Jay: 30 SECONDS, GIRLS.
Julie: I HAVE A SHOE MISSING.
Jay: CLOSE UP THE MASCARA,
GIRLS.
HANDS ON THE CEILING.
WE'RE DONE.
Ann: AAH!
Jay: I WANNA WELCOME YOU GUYS TO
THE ANAND JON SHOWROOM.
THERE IS A PARTY IN BACK
WITH A WHOLE LOT OF
INDUSTRY PEOPLE,
BUT KIARA AND
I ARE GONNA FIGURE OUT
WHICH PERSON IS THE
WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE.
Yaya: HAVING BAD SKIN,
I WAS LESS CONFIDENT
ABOUT THIS COMPETITION.
Jay: DOES KRISTI GET
THIS ONE?
Amanda: I THOUGHT, YOU KNOW,
I LOOKED REALLY GOOD.
I DID FOLLOW THE
MAKEUP INSTRUCTION
REALLY WELL.
Kiara: IT'S SO TOUGH.
Jay: I THINK THE
REASON WE'VE COME UP
WITH THIS ONE WINNER IS JUST
BASED ON, I THINK,
CONCEALING, MAKING THE SKIN LOOK
EVEN, WOULDN'T YOU SAY?
Kiara: YES, BUT STILL
SO NATURAL-LOOKING.
CONGRATULATIONS, NORELLE.
Norelle: AAH!
Jay: SO NOW YOU HAVE TO GIVE
ME THREE NAMES REAL QUICK.
Norelle: OKAY,
EVA, ANN AND KRISTI.
Ann: WHOO!
Norelle: THEY'RE ALL IN
MY ROOM.
THEY'RE THE PEOPLE I SPEND
THE MOST TIME WITH,
AND THEY'RE THE PEOPLE
I FEEL
MOST COMFORTABLE WITH.
Jay: THE FOUR OF YOU GET
TO WEAR ANAND JON
ORIGINAL CREATIONS TO THIS PARTY
TONIGHT.
Eva: OHH!
Kiara: AND THIS IS ANAND.
Anand: HI, EVERYONE. WELCOME.
Julie: I AM INDIAN.
HE'S INDIAN. HEY,
THAT'S COOL.
YOU'RE IN THIS BUSINESS.
I'M TRYING TO DO THIS, TOO.
Anand: THIS IS ONE OF MY
ONE-OF-A-KIND CREATIONS.
Kiara: NOW THE REST OF
YOU WILL BE WEARING THIS.
Ann: AH-HA-HA!
Cassie: OUR LOSER PRIZE WAS TO
BE A SERVER FOR THE NIGHT
AND WEAR THIS HORRIBLE POLYESTER
OUTFIT THAT WAS HOT,
BOW TIE AND EVERYTHING.
Jay: THE FOUR LUCKY LADIES
GET TO GO WITH ANAND
AND TRY ON SOME GOWNS
TO GO TO THE PARTY,
AND THE REST OF YOU GIRLS
PUT ON YOUR UNIFORMS
AND GET STRAIGHT
TO WORK.
Anand: YOU CAN WEAR THIS.
Norelle: MY FIRST INDUSTRY PARTY
IS GONNA BE ONE
THAT I'M NEVER GOING
TO FORGET.
♪♪♪
Kristi: THE PARTY ITSELF
WAS JUST RIDICULOUS.
Anand: VERY DEAR
FRIEND OF MINE.
SHE'S ALSO THE EDITOR
OF "LUXURY FASHION ."
Kristi: SO MANY PERSONALITIES
WEARING RIDICULOUS CLOTHES
AND SHOWING OFF.
Anand: MAY THE BEST
WOMAN WIN.
Women: YAY!
(glass shatters)
Cassie: IN OKLAHOMA,
PEOPLE LOOK AT ME,
AND I DON'T FEEL LIKE PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT ME HERE.
I'M NOT HAVING THAT MUCH FUN,
YOU KNOW?
CAN I GET
A DIET COKE?
Eva: YOU KNOW, THE OTHER LADY
HERE IS INDIAN.
Anand: WHO IS?
Eva: JULIE.
Julie: (Indian
accent) JULIE, YOU'RE STUPID.
WHY ARE YOU ACTING
LIKE A STUPID GIRL?
WHY DO YOU
DRESS LIKE THAT?
BOOBS AND BUTTS ARE
SHOWING THIS WAY AND THAT WAY.
(normal voice) I THINK I'M
SETTING A GOAL
FOR INDIANS.
THEY'RE EITHER ENGINEERS,
DOCTORS, BUT WE CAN GO OUTSIDE
OF THAT.
WE CAN USE OUR INTELLIGENCE
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
(Indian music playing)
Yaya: JULIE CRACKS ME UP.
IT'S NICE TO SEE SOMEBODY PROUD
ABOUT WHERE THEY COME FROM.
Ann: YEAH, BABY.
Anand: THANK YOU, EVERYONE,
FOR COMING.
I HOPE YOU HAD A GOOD TIME.
Kiara: WELL, GOOD LUCK,
EVERYONE.
Ann: THANK YOU.
Eva: THANK YOU.
NICE TO
MEET YOU, TOO.
Toccara: MY FACE NOT OILY LIKE
YOURS.
LIKE YOURS. I'M SORRY.
Yaya: NO, IT'S NOT, TOCCARA,
BECAUSE YOU
HAVE BEAUTIFUL,
CLEAR, NON-OILY SKIN.
Toccara: I GOT ALL THESE BUMPS
ON MY NOSE.
LOOK.
Yaya: GO AHEAD. SLAP HER.
NYAH!
Eva: TYRA MAIL!
Cassie: "IT'S TIME FOR YOUR
CLOSE-UP TO SEE
WHOSE BEAUTY IS TRUE.
BE READY AT 7:30
IN THE MORNING ."
Yaya: BEING WITH SO MANY
BEAUTIFUL WOMEN,
SOME OF THEM HAVE ACTUALLY SAID,
"OH, YEAH, YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL,
BUT I DON'T SEE YOU AS
COMPETITION BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A BUMPY FACE."
Amanda: I THINK THE GIRLS,
SEEING MY BOOST OF CONFIDENCE,
STARTED TREATING ME LESS LIKE A
SAFE PERSON
TO BE AROUND AND MORE
LIKE ACTUAL COMPETITION.
♪♪♪
Jay: BEAUTY REALLY DOES COME
FROM THE INSIDE OUT.
I KNOW THAT'S A CLICHE.
WHEN YOU DO A BEAUTY SHOT, WHICH
IS WHAT WE'RE DOING TODAY,
IT'S ACTUALLY THE MOST DIFFICULT
PHOTOGRAPH TO DO.
TODAY'S SHOOT IS GONNA
BE ABOUT A CLEAN FACE.
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE
ALL THE MAKEUP OFF.
(record needle scratches)
Yaya: WHOA.
Jay: NO LIP GLOSS,
NO BLUSH,
NO BRONZER, NO NOTHING.
SO WE'RE GONNA BE UP TIGHT
AND CLOSE AND PERSONAL.
Yaya: HAVING NO MAKEUP ON, I WAS
REALLY WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS MY LITTLE
INSECURITY.
I WAS LIKE, "OH, THIS TEST IS A
PERSONAL ATTACK AGAINST YAYA ."
♪♪♪
Jay: TODAY'S SHOOT IS GONNA BE
ABOUT A CLEAN FACE.
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE
ALL THE MAKEUP OFF.
I HAVE
MR. TROY WARD HERE.
HE IS AN AMAZING PHOTOGRAPHER.
Troy: I MEAN, TODAY IT'S
REALLY UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL.
IT'S GONNA BE
REALLY JUST YOU.
THERE'S NOWHERE
TO RUN AND HIDE.
Jay: SKIN IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ON MODELS.
AND ESPECIALLY YOUR
HANDS WILL SHOW YOUR AGE.
SO NIVEA HAS GIVEN US
HAND CREAM TODAY,
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU'LL
REALLY BE MODELING.
ALL RIGHT,
SO LET'S GET CRACKIN'.
♪♪♪
Julie: WE GOTTA HAVE
PRETTY HANDS.
Danilo: HOW DOES IT
FEEL WAKING UP WITH THIS?
HAVE YOU BEEN POSSESSED BY
THE PREVIOUS OWNER?
Woman: THANK YOU.
Jay: READY?
Danilo: ANN, OUR
FIRST VICTIM.
Troy: BEAUTIFUL.
Jay: YOU'RE STARTING
TO THINK.
DON'T HOLD THAT JAW.
Troy: TOCCARA.
THAT'S NICE.
COME BACK TO ME WITH YOUR EYES.
BEAUTIFUL.
Jay: JUST LONG, ELEGANT,
YOU CONJURE UP
IMAN OR SOMETHING.
OH! OH, LOOK AT THAT.
BAM, BAM, BAM.
Nicole: I WAS TRYING
TO THROW, LIKE,
"I AM IN THE MIDDLE OF SEX RIGHT
NOW, " KIND OF, YOU KNOW,
PLAYING WITH THE HAIR
AND GRABBING YOUR NECK.
Jay: EVA, JUST REMEMBER,
THINK SOME OF THESE
REALLY BEAUTIFUL MOMENTS.
Troy: BEAUTIFUL RIGHT THERE.
GOOD.
Danilo: YOU KNOW "MONA LISA,"
THE PAINTING?
Kristi: YES.
Danilo: YOU KNOW, HOW, LIKE...
(drones in monotone)
Kristi: YES.
Danilo: DON'T GO THERE.
IT DOESN'T
SELL PRODUCTS.
Jay: KRISTI, HEAD UP TO THE
LIGHT.
Troy: LEAN FORWARD AND TILT
YOUR--EXACTLY.
DROP THAT SHOULDER.
KRISTI WAS NERVOUS.
I THINK SHE WAS PROBABLY THE
MOST LIMITED OF ALL
THE GIRLS AS FAR AS THE LOOKS.
Jay: READY?
Yaya: I'M USED TO
NOT WEARING
ANY MAKEUP, BUT
I'M NOT USED
TO BEING IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA
WHILE DOING SO.
Troy: TURN BACK AROUND TO ME A
LITTLE BIT MORE THOUGH.
YEAH, RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S IT.
Yaya: AT FIRST, I WAS KIND OF
WORRIED ABOUT IT.
BUT AFTER GETTING
MY HAIR DONE
AND PREPARING
MYSELF MENTALLY,
SPIRITUALLY, I WAS LIKE, "OKAY,
I CAN DO THIS ."
Troy: BEAUTIFUL.
Jay: YAYA IS A TROOPER.
SHE SAT IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA
WITH NO MAKEUP ON AND SAID,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS IS MY SKIN,
BUT I'M GONNA BE
BEAUTIFUL ."
Troy: WE'RE DONE.
Yaya: YAY!
Jay: JENNIPHER, YOU GOTTA BRING
YOUR CHIN DOWN.
Troy: IF YOU HAVE GREAT
THOUGHTS, BECAUSE THAT'S
GONNA COME THROUGH.
GIVE ME A LITTLE
BIT OF A SMILE.
Jay: TROY, SHE JUST GOT HER
BRACES OFF TWO DAYS AGO.
Troy: REALLY?
DO YOU FEEL LIKE
A NEW WOMAN?
SO NO ONE'S GONNA RECOGNIZE
YOU BACK HOME.
Norelle: NO.
Jay: I THINK NORELLE IS GONNA
REALLY HAVE TO GO WORK
IN THE MIRROR AND FIND
CONFIDENCE WITHIN HER FACE.
Troy: OKAY.
A LITTLE BIT OF A SMILE.
JULIE, YOU SHAKE A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT HAIR OUT.
YUP.
BRING ONE PIECE THROUGH IT.
YEAH.
Julie: I KIND OF LOOKED IN HIS
CAMERA, AND I WAS SAYING,
LIKE, "OH, YOU KNOW,
WHAT AM I SUPPOSED
TO BE LOOKING FOR? "
Jay: THINK OF
ELONGATING THE NECK.
Troy: BUT REALLY
STAY STRONG TO ME.
THAT'S IT.
A LITTLE MORE HAND. YUP.
OKAY, THAT'S NICE. DO THAT.
THAT'S GREAT.
Julie: I DON'T THINK
I CONNECTED WELL
WITH THE CAMERA, SO I'M
JUST SORT OF, LIKE,
IN THE DARK, LIKE, "OKAY, I'M
JUST GONNA TWIRL MY HAIR
LIKE THEY WANT ME TO."
Troy: OKAY.
I THINK THAT'S IT.
GOOD. LONG NECK THOUGH.
STAY UP.
Jay: THINK OUTSIDE OF THE BOX
FOR US.
GIVE ME A FEW
MORE EXPRESSIONS
KELLE, A LITTLE MORE LIFE.
THAT DOESN'T
MEAN WIDE-EYED,
IT JUST MEANS
A LITTLE MORE LIFE.
Troy: LIPS TOGETHER.
Toccara: KELLE WAS THERE.
THEY KEPT TRYING TO GET
SOMETHING OUT OF HER
THAT SHE JUST
WASN'T GIVING.
Jay: JUST NEVER PRESS
INTO YOUR FACE.
Amanda: YEAH.
Jay: INTIMATE. INTIMATE.
Amanda: THE MAKEOVER REALLY KIND
OF BOOSTED MY CONFIDENCE.
AND I THINK,
YOU KNOW,
I'VE GOT
A STRONG PERSONALITY
AND A STRONG TALENT.
Jay: PRETTY.
OH, SHE JUST
BECAME SO STUNNING.
Amanda: I TOTALLY FEEL
IT AND COMPLETELY,
COMPLETELY WORKED IT.
Jennipher: CASSIE INFORMED
AMANDA THAT SHE WAS BULIMIC.
AMANDA TOLD SOMEBODY,
AND THE NEXT
THING YOU KNOW,
EVERYBODY KNOWS,
OF COURSE.
Norelle: IT'S GONNA
EAT HER ALIVE.
IT'S JUST LIKE, THAT'S SUCH A
HUGE SECRET, YOU KNOW?
LIKE, ANYONE WHO
DOES THAT MUST
FEEL, LIKE, HORRIBLE INSIDE.
Cassie: DON'T GO IN THERE.
I FELT VERY SICK
IN MY STOMACH.
Ann: SHE HAS POTENTIAL TO BE SO
GOOD, BUT SHE--
YOU DON'T NEED TO DO THAT.
LITTLE GIRLS
CAN'T THINK THAT,
"OH, I WANT TO BE
A MODEL, "
LIKE, "I'M GONNA HAVE TO MAKE
MYSELF PUKE ."
Jennipher: NOW THAT I THINK
ABOUT IT, SHE'S ALWAYS TIRED.
SHE HAS NO ENERGY.
Ann: IT'S SO
NOT HEALTHY.
IT ROTS YOUR TEETH.
WHO IS SHE THE
CLOSEST TO HERE?
SOMEONE NEEDS TO
SIT HER DOWN AND TALK TO HER.
Cassie: I SHOULD'VE NEVER OPENED
UP, AND I SHOULD HAVE
NEVER TRUSTED
THESE GIRLS.
I THINK THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
MAKE IT WORSE
AND PLAY UP CASSIE AS THIS
MENTALLY UNSTABLE
BULIMIC GIRL WHO
DOES BAD THINGS
TO LOSE WEIGHT,
AND SHE CAN NEVER
BE A MODEL.
SHE SHOULDN'T BE HERE.
Troy: NICE. RIGHT THERE. GOOD. I
LOVE THAT RIGHT THERE.
NOW JUST GIVE ME
A LITTLE TILT OVER.
RIGHT THERE. BEAUTIFUL.
Jay: I CAN'T TELL YOU'RE
INSECURE,
AND THAT'S GOOD.
Cassie: OKAY.
Jay: CASSIE NEEDS VALIDATION. AS
SOON AS SHE HAS IT,
SHE REALLY BECOMES A MODEL.
Troy: RIGHT THERE.
Eva: AMANDA IS A COMPLETE ASS
FOR TELLING CASSIE'S SECRET.
SHE PLAYS THIS ROLE THAT
SHE'S THIS SWEET,
NURTURING MOTHER.
IF SOMEONE DECIDES
TO CONFIDE IN YOU,
WHY DON'T YOU LET THAT BE
BETWEEN YOU AND THAT PERSON?
Cassie: I HAVE A WILL TO BE
SKINNY, AND IF PEOPLE
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT,
THAT'S THEIR PROBLEM,
NOT MINE.
Troy: GOOD.
Amanda: WHAT THE HELL WAS CASSIE
THINKING,
SAYING IT TO ME,
IF SHE DIDN'T WANT
ANYBODY TO KNOW, AND IF SHE
DIDN'T WANT HELP FOR IT?
Troy: WHAT DO WE THINK?
Jay: YEAH, TROY, I THINK
WE GOT IT.
Cassie: I DON'T CARE WHAT THESE
GIRLS THINK ANYMORE.
I'M STILL GONNA DO ME, AND I'M
STILL GONNA TRY
TO WIN THIS THING.
♪♪♪
Julie: THAT LOOKS
LIKE SHRIMP CURRY.
GOOD.
Eva: DID RICE COME
WITH OUR FOOD?
Cassie: HEY, GUYS, IF YOU
HAVEN'T COME TO ME
ABOUT WHAT
EVERYONE'S SAYING
ABOUT THE PAST PROBLEMS
THAT I'VE HAD WITH EATING,
THEN IT'S NOT AN
ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
IT'S NOT A PROBLEM HERE.
SO IF YOU ALL THINK THAT
I'M STILL THROWING UP
OR SOMETHING HERE,
THEN IT'S NOT THE CASE.
Yaya: I CAN SEE WHY
SHE MIGHT FEEL ALONE
AND WHY SHE MIGHT BE JUST REALLY
HURT BY THE FACT
THAT PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HER.
Cassie: I DON'T CONSIDER
MYSELF BULIMIC,
BECAUSE I DON'T THROW UP
AFTER EVERYTHING I EAT.
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS, COME TO
ME AND DON'T
JUST TALK ABOUT IT,
YOU KNOW?
Nicole: I HONESTLY DIDN'T
KNOW WHAT THE ISSUE WAS.
Cassie: YEAH.
WELL, JUST,
PEOPLE ARE LIKE,
"OH, MY GOD, CASSIE
IS BULIMIC HERE.
SHE'S THROWING UP."
I CAN'T EVEN REMEMBER
THE LAST TIME I THREW UP.
Jennipher: EVEN IF YOU DID, OR
WHEN YOU GO HOME OR WHATEVER,
IT'S JUST BAD
ON YOUR HEALTH.
Cassie: YEAH. I HAVE
AN OBSESSION WITH
MY WEIGHT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
I'M NOT BULIMIC,
THOUGH.
I HAVE GROWN UP DREAMING
OF BEING A MODEL.
AND GREAT,
THERE'S PLUS-SIZE MODELS,
BUT THAT'S NOT
FOR ME.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IT ANYMORE,
AND I DON'T WANT ANYONE ELSE
TALKING ABOUT IT ANYMORE,
REALLY.
Ann: IF YOU MAKE YOURSELF
THROW UP TO LOSE WEIGHT,
THAT'S AN EATING DISORDER.
LIKE, NO MATTER WHEN--
IF YOU DO IT ONCE,
IF YOU DO IT
FIVE TIMES.
Eva: ANN COMES AND
TELLS ME.
SHE'S LIKE... (whispering)
"AMANDA SAYS THAT CASSIE'S
ANOREXIC AND BULIMIC ."
I AM SO BLOWN RIGHT NOW, I
JUST--THE WHOLE SITUATION
WITH AMANDA-- I DON'T
TRUST ANYBODY.
SHE JUST WANTS SOMEONE
ELSE OUT OF THE RUNNING,
BECAUSE SHE WANTS
THE UPPER HAND.
THAT'S ALL AMANDA WAS TRYING TO
DO, BECAUSE SHE IS
INTIMIDATED BY CASSIE,
'CAUSE CASSIE'S BEAUTIFUL.
Amanda: CAN YOU TELL ME I'M A
GOOD PERSON?
Amanda's mother: Well,
you know you are.
Amanda: I DID SOMETHING WRONG,
AND I SHOULDN'T HAVE.
I JUST TOLD SOMETHING THAT A
GIRL TOLD ME IN CONFIDENCE.
I FEEL SO BAD.
Amanda's mother: Just try and
stay out
of all that crapola.
Amanda: WHAT I DID TO CASSIE
WITH BRINGING HER SECRET
OUT IN THE OPEN,
IT WASN'T MY PLACE TO
DO IT.
AND NOW I'M
THE EVIL PERSON,
AND EVERYBODY THINKS
I'M A BACKSTABBER.
♪♪♪
Woman: TYRA MAIL.
Nicole: "TOMORROW YOU WILL
MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 11 OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
ON IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL
BE ELIMINATED ."
Toccara: I'M SO HAPPY!
SOMEBODY'S
GOING HOME!
Nicole: I'M EXCITED, ACTUALLY,
FOR ELIMINATIONS.
I'M GOING, "LET'S GET SOME OF
THESE BITCHES OUT OF HERE ."
Cassie: I WANT TO BE
HERE, 'CAUSE THIS IS MY DREAM,
YOU KNOW?
Eva: CAN'T BE ANOREXIC.
YOU CAN'T BE BULIMIC.
YOU CAN'T BE MAKING YOURSELF
SICK.
I THINK SHE WILL BE ELIMINATED
IF IT GOES BACK TO TYRA.
♪♪♪
Tyra: WELCOME, LADIES.
THIS WEEK YOU GUYS HAD
SOME GORGEOUS MAKEOVERS.
LOOK AT YOU.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGING PANEL
TO MAKE THE THIRD CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TO FINDING
OUT WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE HAVE SOME
AMAZING PRIZES--
A MODELING CONTRACT WITH THE TOP
MODELING AGENCY--
FORD MODELS,
A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE WHICH
WILL BE SHOT
BY THE WORLD-RENOWNED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR ME
TO INTRODUCE OUR PANEL
OF INTERESTING, WACKY BUT HIGHLY
INTELLIGENT JUDGES--
JANICE DICKINSON,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODELS,
NIGEL BARKER, WHO IS A
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
NOLE MARIN, WHO IS
A PROMINENT
FASHION
EDITOR AND STYLIST.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE,
THIS WEEK WE HAVE A GUEST
JUDGE--
HAIRSTYLIST TO ALL THE TOP
MODELS--DANILO.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR EVALUATIONS.
AND THEN THE JUDGES
WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE WHICH
ONE OF YOU
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED.
BUT FIRST JAY IS
GONNA ADMINISTER YOUR TEST.
Jay: TODAY WE'RE GONNA TEST YOU
ON WHAT YOU LEARNED
ABOUT APPLYING MAKEUP.
WE HAVE A PACK OF MAKEUP
SUPPLIED TO YOU BY COVER GIRL
ON ALL OF YOUR BEDS.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TEN MINUTES TO
APPLY TO HALF OF YOUR FACE
A CLEAN, DAY LOOK AND APPLY A
NIGHT, DIVA LOOK
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
ALL RIGHT? GO!
Women: (screaming)
♪♪♪
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
THE FIRST GIRL IS KRISTI.
Janice: YOU LOOK LIKE
COUSIN IT.
Nolé: I LOVE THE WISPY
BANGS ALL IN YOUR EYE.
I REALLY AM IMPRESSED WITH YOU.
MAKEUP?
THE EVENING LOOKS
PRETTY GOOD.
SO YOU HAD A CLOSE-UP
BEAUTY SHOOT.
THERE WERE TWO THINGS
THAT YOU WERE BEING
JUDGED ON WITH
THIS SHOOT.
ONE IS YOUR POSING
AND HOW WELL YOU TAKE
A BEAUTY PHOTOGRAPH.
THE OTHER IS HOW
MUCH RETOUCHING YOU NEED.
RETOUCHING'S
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE.
A CLIENT DOESN'T WANT TO HAVE
TO PAY TONS OF MONEY
TO GET THE GIRL THAT HE HIRED
FOR A JOB'S SKIN RETOUCHED.
HERE WAS KRISTI'S
BEST SHOT.
Janice: YAWN.
Tyra: I THINK THE
MOUTH IS BEAUTIFUL.
I THINK THE EYES ARE DEAD.
CAN WE SEE
THE UNRETOUCHED?
Janice: DEAD.
Nolé: THAT IS SO
NOT GOOD.
Tyra: EVA.
Janice: EVA DIVA.
Nigel: I DON'T REALLY SEE
A BIG DIFFERENCE.
IT'S VERY EVEN FROM
ONE SIDE TO THE OTHER,
AND FROM THIS DISTANCE,
I REALLY CAN'T TELL.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR
BEST SHOT.
Janice: I WANT TO CLIP
THE ARTIFICIAL NAIL,
AS IT LOOKS
VERY HOOKER.
Tyra: EVA, I THINK THIS PICTURE
IS ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
Danilo: YOU'VE CAPTURED SORT OF
THE ESSENCE OF THE AD.
Tyra: CAN WE SEE EVA'S
UNRETOUCHED PHOTO?
Janice: OH, GOD!
HELP! STOP,
IN THE NAME OF LOVE.
Tyra: CASSIE.
HERE IS YOUR
BEST SHOT.
Janice: THAT'S PERFECT.
Nigel: THE HAND--
IT LOOKS NOT SO GREAT.
Nolé: LOOKS LIKE AN OLD
LADY'S HAND TO ME.
Tyra: CAN WE SEE
THE UNRETOUCHED PICTURE?
Nigel: HEY, THAT
IS NOT BAD.
Janice: ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THAT'S BETTER THAN
THE RETOUCHED PICTURE.
Tyra: JENNIPHER.
Janice: WOW.
BIG CHANGE. HOW DO YOU FEEL?
Jennipher: I FEEL BETTER NOW.
Tyra: ARE YOU READY FOR YOUR
BEST SHOT?
Jennipher: I THINK SO.
Tyra: HERE IT IS.
Nigel: OKAY, IT'S NOT REALLY
DOING MUCH FOR ME.
Janice: WHAT'S KILLING US IS,
YOU HAVE WHAT IT TAKES,
AND YOU'RE NOT
BRINGING IT.
Tyra: LET'S SEE JENNIPHER
WITH NO RETOUCHING.
Nigel: EH, IT'S JUST STILL
BORING.
YOU'VE JUST GOT BAGS NOW.
Tyra: AMANDA.
Nolé: HEY, AMANDA.
Janice: MANDY!
Nolé: WHERE DID YOU COME
FROM, BABY?
Amanda: YOUR DREAMS.
Tyra: ANNIE LENNOX MEETS
DARYL HANNAH
FROM "SPLASH."
Nolé: HOW DO YOU LIKE IT?
Amanda: AS SOON AS I SAW IT, I
WAS LIKE, "I FEEL THE SEX ."
Tyra: YOU HAVE SO MUCH MAKEUP
ON YOUR DAY FACE.
Janice: THANK YOU.
Nolé: I MEAN, IT LOOKS LIKE
EXACTLY THE SAME, UNFORTUNATELY.
Amanda: OKAY.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY?
HERE IS YOUR BEST
SHOT, AMANDA.
Janice: GORGEOUS.
COVER OF DANISH
"VOGUE ."
Nolé: YOU'VE REALLY
TURNED IT OUT.
LAST WEEK,
YOU WERE A BROKEN
RAG DOLL,
AND NOW YOU'RE OUR QUEEN.
Tyra: YOUR UNRETOUCHED PHOTO.
OH. IT'S SO--THAT'S IT.
Nolé: THAT'S IT?
Tyra: THAT'S AMAZING.
Nigel: I ALMOST
DIDN'T NOTICE.
(light applause)
Tyra: NICOLE.
Nigel: HEY, PETER PAN.
Danilo: I'M LOVING YOUR
COLOR CHANGE.
Nigel: IT'S MADE YOUR
WHOLE FACE COME ALIVE.
Janice: THERE'S CONFIDENCE IN
YOUR FACE HERE.
YOU'VE ABSOLUTELY WOWED ME.
Tyra: UNRETOUCHED PHOTO.
Janice: STILL GOOD.
Tyra: TOCCARA.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: WHOA!
Tyra: THAT IS GORGEOUS!
Danilo: WATCHING YOU POSE IN
FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
IT CAME QUITE NATURALLY
TO YOU.
Tyra: LET'S SEE
THE UNRETOUCHED ONE.
Janice: SKIN AS FINE
AS HONEY.
Tyra: NORELLE.
NORELLE GOT
HER BRACES OFF.
Janice: YOU FEEL LIKE WORKING
IT, DON'T YOU?
THEY'RE
LOVELY, YOUR TEETH.
Nolé: DEAR, YOU LOOK LIKE A
MODEL.
Tyra: GIRL, I THINK YOUR MAKEUP
IS FABULOUS.
Norelle: THANK YOU.
Tyra: THE HEAVY SIDE REMINDED ME
OF WINONA RYDER
ON THE RED CARPET.
Nolé: MM-HMM.
Danilo: THAT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'VE GOT EVERY HAND
IN THE PHOTO.
I WANT TO TAKE SOME OF THAT
AWAY.
I WANT TO SEE A LITTLE
MORE OF YOUR BEAUTY.
Tyra: NOW WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
LOOK
AT YOUR UNRETOUCHED PHOTO.
Janice: HELP!
I NEED BLINDERS.
Tyra: ANN.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: YOU'RE NOT UTILIZING
THAT PERFECT OVAL FACE
AND THE CONFIDENCE TO
WEAR YOUR HAIR BACK.
Nigel: I DON'T LIKE
IT EITHER.
Tyra: LET'S SEE
ANN'S NON-RETOUCHED PHOTO.
Nigel: YOU NEED TO GET THIS
THERE.
Nolé: YEAH.
Tyra: JULIE.
Nolé: WHY DIDN'T YOU WORK
ON YOUR EYES MORE?
THE EVENING LOOK, THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH ON THE EYE.
WHY DIDN'T YOU PLAY IT UP MORE?
Nigel: EMBRACE THE INDIAN AND
ETHNIC ROOTS THAT YOU HAVE.
Janice: WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
YOUR OUTFIT, HONEY?
Nolé: IT'S NOT
A MODEL OUTFIT.
Tyra: CAN WE TAKE THE NECKLACE
OFF AND, LIKE,
ROLL THE PANTS DOWN?
Nolé: SHE SHOULD TAKE DOWN HER
HAIR.
Janice: YOU'RE LOOKING
PEDESTRIAN HERE, HONEY.
Nolé: THE EYES ARE NOT THERE,
THE ANGLE--
YOU'RE NOT WORKING IT.
Tyra: UNRETOUCHED PHOTO.
Janice: I WANT TO KNOW WHY YOU
WANT TO BE A MODEL.
Julie: HONESTLY, IT'S FOR ME TO
GET INTO THIS INDUSTRY
AND TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT IT,
FOR ME TO START MY OWN APPAREL
MANUFACTURING COMPANY.
Janice: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
YOU WANT TO START A
MANUFACTURING COMPANY?
Julie: YEAH.
I NEVER HAD THAT, LIKE, MODEL
CONFIDENCE, THOUGH.
Janice: OH,
YOU DIDN'T WANT TO BE A MODEL.
YOU WANT TO BE A MANUFACTURER.
Nigel: YOU'VE GOT TO CONCENTRATE
ON THE JOB AT HAND.
THE JOB AT HAND
IS MODELING.
Tyra: OKAY, THANKS, JULIE.
UP NEXT WE HAVE YAYA.
Janice: YAYA!
Tyra: HERE IS YOUR
BEST SHOT.
Janice: LOOKING GOOD HERE,
GIRLFRIEND.
Tyra: I WASN'T SURE IF YOU WERE
GONNA EVER BE ABLE
TO BE SO SOFT, AND THIS PICTURE
LOOKS MORE INNOCENT, AND IT'S
REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
LET'S SEE
YOUR UNRETOUCHED PHOTO.
Nigel: YOU HAVE TO
WORK ON THE SKIN.
DRINK MORE WATER.
WATER, WATER, WATER.
Tyra: YOU COULD GET THERE, BUT
IT'S GONNA TAKE SOME WORK.
AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST--KELLE.
Janice: KELLE, YOU'RE A
SLAMMIN', FIERCE--
THIS CHANGE
IS AMAZING.
Nigel: I LIKE YOUR HAIR
A LOT.
Nolé: GIRL, THERE'S NOTHING ON
YOUR--I MEAN, THAT LITTLE BIT
OF BLUE ON TOP,
BUT THAT'S IT.
Tyra: YOU HAVE TO PUT ON MORE
MAKEUP AS A WOMAN OF COLOR.
OUR SKIN ABSORBS THE LIGHT.
IT DOESN'T
REFLECT THE LIGHT.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: OVERALL,
THIS PICTURE IS JUST BLAND.
Nigel: YOU LOOK LIKE A DEER IN
THE HEADLIGHTS
IN THIS PICTURE.
Janice: PERFECT,
ALMOND-SHAPE EYES.
THERE'S NOTHING
COMING BEHIND IT.
LET'S SEE YOUR
UNRETOUCHED SHOT.
Nigel: (groans)
Janice: IT'S LIKE
A HITCHCOCK FILM.
GO BACK AND FORTH REALLY FAST
TO SEE WHAT I MEAN.
EEH, OOH. EEH, OOH.
AHH! OOH!
Tyra: WHAT ARE YOU FEELING RIGHT
NOW, KELLE?
YOU LOOK A LITTLE--
Kelle: IT'S VERY SHOCKING TO SEE
IT LIKE THIS.
THE PEOPLE THAT USUALLY SEE MY
SKIN TELL ME
THAT I HAVE
BEAUTIFUL SKIN.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
MY EYES WERE VERY INTENSE.
Tyra: BUT IF IT WAS INTENSE AND
BETTER THAN THIS,
THEY WOULD
HAVE CHOSEN THIS SHOT.
Kelle: I KNOW. THAT'S TRUE.
Tyra: YOU CANNOT PLACE THE BLAME
ON SOMEONE ELSE.
Kelle: I'M NOT BLAMING--
Tyra: NO, YES, YOU ARE.
RIGHT NOW, YOU'RE NOT GROWING.
Nigel: TAKE ALL THE CRITICISM WE
GIVE YOU
AND USE IT CONSTRUCTIVELY AND BE
EMPOWERED BY IT,
AND WALK AWAY AND GO, "OKAY, NOW
I KNOW WHAT TO DO ."
Tyra: IF YOU WALK OUT OF HERE
SAYING, "THE PHOTOGRAPHER
CHOSE THE WRONG PICTURE,"
YOU DON'T GROW.
Kelle: YOU'RE RIGHT.
Tyra: OKAY, KELLE, THANK YOU.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE.
♪♪♪
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
WE WILL START WITH EVA.
Janice: I'M DIGGING EVA.
Danilo: DANILO THINKS SHE'S
BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: JENNIPHER.
Nigel: STRIKING,
YET THIS PICTURE IS BLAH.
Danilo: JENNIPHER'S OUT IN THIS
PHOTO, BUT HER BEAUTY
IS DEFINITELY IN.
Tyra: ANN.
Nigel: THIS PICTURE, FOR ME--
ANN LOOKS LIKE NOTHING.
Nolé: I DON'T THINK SHE'S USING
HERSELF ENOUGH.
Tyra: YAYA.
Danilo: YAYA IS A YES, YES.
IN.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Nigel: I DO NOT GET THIS GIRL.
Janice: SHE LOOKS LIKE
A PARAKEET.
Tyra: SHE'S MODERN. KRISTI.
Janice: OH, MY GOD. HELP.
Danilo: SHE'S GIVING ME AN OUT.
Tyra: JULIE.
Nigel: IN PERSON,
SHE'S A REALLY BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
Tyra: I WAS EXTREMELY TURNED OFF
WHEN SHE SAID
SHE WAS USING THE
MODELING WORLD
TO GET SOMEWHERE ELSE.
AMANDA.
Janice: THIS IS FLAWLESS.
Nigel: YEAH, IT IS.
Janice: IT'S JUST PERFECT.
Tyra: TOCCARA.
Danilo: A KILLER FIGURE.
Janice: YOU ALL KNOW HOW I FEEL
ABOUT LARGE WOMEN
IN COUTURE.
Tyra: CASSIE.
Nolé: SHE'S TOO PLAIN.
SHE'S OUT.
Nigel: THE PICTURE IS PRETTY.
IT'S NICE.
IT'S NOT FANTASTIC.
Tyra: NICOLE.
Danilo: I'D LOVE TO SEE NICOLE
PUMP UP THE VOLUME.
Janice: I THINK SHE HAS A SHOT.
Tyra: KELLE.
Nolé: WHEN I SEE KELLE, I THINK
SHE'S AN ABSOLUTELY
GORGEOUS GIRL.
Nigel: I DON'T LIKE PEOPLE TO
TALK ABOUT THEMSELVES LIKE,
"I'M THIS BEAUTIFUL PERSON."
LET US TELL YOU
YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: SHE TRIES TO BLAME HER
LACK OF INTENSITY
ON OTHER PEOPLE.
Janice: I'M FEELING TOCCARA OVER
KELLE, I REALLY AM.
Nolé: WOW.
Janice: I'M FEELING THAT.
♪♪♪
Tyra: I HAVE 12 BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STANDING BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE 11 PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE 11 OF YOU
THAT WILL CONTINUE
ON THE JOURNEY
TO POSSIBLY BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
Tyra: AMANDA.
CONGRATULATIONS, AMANDA.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NICOLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
EVA.
YAYA.
TOCCARA.
JENNIPHER.
CASSIE.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU WERE
GIVING UP OVER THERE, CASSIE.
Cassie: NO.
Tyra: THE NEXT NAME THAT I WILL
CALL--NORELLE.
SHOWING THAT PRETTY NEW
SMILE, AREN'T YOU?
Tyra: ANN.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL--
KRISTI.
Tyra: YOU WERE HAVING
A PANIC ATTACK OVER THERE.
Kristi: YOU HAVE NO IDEA.
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS, KRISTI.
WILL JULIE AND KELLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS THE
GIRL THAT WILL CONTINUE
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE GIRL'S NAME THAT
I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO YOUR APARTMENT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND LEAVE.
YOU TWO HAD SOME OF THE
WORST PICTURES IN THE BUNCH--
NO INTENSITY,
NO FIRE AND NO PASSION.
KELLE, YOU
PLAYED THE BLAME GAME.
YOU DON'T TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR YOURSELF.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO HEAR
THE CRITIQUE AND SAY,
"I CAN DO BETTER,"
NOT "SOMEONE ELSE CAN
CHOOSE A BETTER PHOTO ."
JULIE, YOU SAID THAT
YOU WANT TO BE HERE
TO FURTHER YOUR CAREER IN
FASHION MERCHANDISING
OR MANUFACTURING.
NOT ONCE DID YOU SAY YOU
WANT TO BE A TOP MODEL.
I FEEL LIKE YOU
BOTH LACK PASSION,
AND I'M SO DISAPPOINTED
IN BOTH OF YOU.
Tyra: KELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Kelle: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Tyra: YOU'RE STILL IN THE
RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT
TOP MODEL.
Kelle: I CAN DO BETTER.
Tyra: THERE YOU GO.
THANK YOU, JULIE.
Julie: THANK YOU.
I REALLY ACTUALLY THOUGHT I WAS
GONNA GET FARTHER,
BUT, I MEAN, THE TRUTH CAME OUT.
I SAW THIS AS A DREAM FOR NOW,
BUT THEN I SAW
A BIGGER DREAM
IN THE END.
MY MAIN DRIVE WASN'T MODELING,
AND IT'S THE FIRST TIME
IN MY LIFE WHEN I'M REALLY
HONEST ABOUT SOMETHING,
AND I BLOW IT HERE. AND BESIDE
THAT,
IT'S OVER NOW.
TYRA: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE...
COMING UP ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL, "
THE GIRLS STRUT THEIR STUFF
WITH MISS J. ALEXANDER.
J.: YOU'RE ABOUT TO
FALL, BUT YOU'RE NOT
LETTING IT HAPPEN.
Eva: IT'S NOT GONNA FALL.
J.: OH!
Tyra: AND THEY DO IT
WITH THE HELP
OF LAST YEAR'S WINNER...
Man: MISS "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
MODEL" HERSELF...
Tyra: YOANNA.
Tyra: A SURPRISE RUNWAY SHOW
IS A DREAM COME TRUE
FOR NORELLE.
Women: (screaming)
Tyra: BUT WILL
AMANDA'S NIGHT BLINDNESS
BE HER RUNWAY TO ELIMINATION?
Amanda: I'M GETTING
SCARED NOW.